an investigation has been launched by
parliament's standards Watchdog into
Rishi sunac and a possible failure to
declare an interest in the last few
minutes Downing Street's sources have
said that the investigation relates to
shares that his wife holds in a Child
Care Agency Sky's political
correspondent Rob Powell joins us now
from Westminster with more on this
developing story rob you are suggesting
that this could be what it's about
um how is it possible that the Prime
Minister hasn't declared it as an
interest if we all knew about it
so it was when he was being questioned
by MPS on the liaison committee about an
announcement that came in the budget
last month that was essentially uh
introducing bonuses if people additional
payments for child minders signing up
um to get into the professional signing
up through an agency so the overall aim
was to try and boost the number of child
minders that were uh out there and able
to take on work which of course came as
part of a broader package about
expanding child care for parents of
younger children as well and what the
allegation was at the time was
essentially when Rishi sunak was being
asked about the specifics of this he
hadn't flagged up in that instant that
his wife was a shareholder in an agency
that would potentially benefit from this
policy announcement I think as well
people pointed to the list of
ministerial interests which hasn't
actually been updated for quite a while
in part given the upheaval because of
the standards advisor changing quite so
frequently in the last year or so that
they they claimed it wasn't spelled out
clearly enough there that he had a link
obviously through his wife to an agency
that could potentially benefit so
essentially uh yes it was out there in
the press or was reported shortly after
he made this appearance
um liaison committee but really the sort
of rules and the code of conduct of
parliament is such that you have to take
formal steps to outline these potential
interests so that any potential conflict
of interest in what you are doing in
your political day job and your personal
interests you have are set out and are
transparent so as you say a dining
Street Source has now confirmed that
this standards commissioner inquiry that
was started last Thursday is related to
this potential issue of shares that
Rishi sunak's wife of Charlton merty has
in an agency called koru kids that this
investigation will go on to see whether
he has declared all of that properly now
it's understood what the kind of Defense
if you like from the prime minister is
is that actually because the register of
ministerial interests where the Prime
Minister and other ministers declare
potential interests or potential
Financial interests and other
connections that could give rise to
potential conflicts of interest because
that hasn't been published a new one
hasn't come out in from my memory a year
or so now maybe even longer actually
that in the new ministerial of in
register of interest that will be coming
out fairly soon hopefully that's been
worked on by the standards advisor now
that that will actually be detailed
there so I think that will be part of
the defense by number 10 but I mean the
standards advisor investigating does so
and then comes back and decides whether
the code of conduct has been broken if
it has that's where when um the focus
shifts on what kind of punishment what
kind of sanction could be put forward it
can range from an apology to the house
to being suspect from the house
obviously that is quite far down the
line but it is clearly
um serious but I think from The Briefing
that is coming out right now number 10
seem confident that actually the
appropriate declarations have been made
but this is now a case of the standards
commissioner going through the protocol
and investigating this and given there's
quite a few different MPS that are being
investigated by the commissioner at the
moment that may well take some time